[Music]
thank you
hi there good afternoon everybody uh
welcome to the what's new with bigquery
uh session
um my name's Dave Nettleton I'm going to
be one of your presenters today
get the right direction of the clicker
um with me uh two co-presenters uh
Daniel who's uh from Discord one of our
fabulous customers and has fans already
God all right I didn't even get I can
get a woo
um and then Thomas talius who leads the
engineering team uh for bigquery and
then myself Dave Nettleton I lead the
product management team uh for bigquery
and I'm very excited today to walk you
through uh what's new with bigquery
um I'm probably gonna I'm gonna cover
two main sections of uh materials some
is announcements at next but I also want
to take a little bit of the time to kind
of go through and just highlight some of
the releases that from earlier in the
year as well
um so you know just starting with a
little bit of background and the context
for how we see and think about bigquery
how our customers are using it and the
the success we see in the market with it
um you know for many many years and I've
been very fortunate through maybe 20
years or more of my career I've had a
chance to work with a lot of customers
around how they can take best advantage
of data and AI
um uh you know this might be from the
old days of sort of data warehousing
databases traditional ETL type systems
through the area of um uh data lakes and
Hadoop and hadooper system but behind
all of that is this urge and this need
from customers to drive more value from
their data one of our customers once put
this to me really well and really super
succinctly which is I only need to do
two things I need to make money and I
need to save money and in doing both of
those things depending on where you are
often in the business cycle there's
different pressures from the business it
always comes back to being able to use
data and AI to help generate
um that value for your business and we
see consistently customers who are able
to do that are able to generate much
better business performance than those
who still struggle with some of the
challenges of using data and AI so you
know we have the privilege to hopefully
burn then build a product with bigquery
to really simplify this and make it
easier for for customers
um I guess I couldn't get very far in
without talking about uh generative AI
you know it's been a very uh Hot Topic
uh for the last year
um you know and this is really sort of
accelerated a lot of these conversations
around data right now people have been
trying to get value out of data they've
been using AI for many years generative
AI is adding a sort of a net new set of
capabilities it's one of those rare
occurrences when there's been a step
function in the algorithm capabilities
with the sort of the Transformer
capability and the ability to handle
more ambiguity
um in for example language the scale of
processing power and algorithms through
the super powerful tpus and gpus that
are available and then also just the
scale of data for training right so
those three things have combined into
this really interesting step function
that has made a new set of possibilities
um uh super interesting for customers to
uh to explore so whether that's data
analysts looking to be more productive
in finding insights and data whether
it's customer support calls and
conversations and interactive chat Bots
many many uh organizations are exploring
how to take advantage of generated by
within their businesses today
um so for us you know we just wanted to
reflect for a second on why are people
choosing Google Cloud today for their
data and AI Journey
um and uh and how has you know how have
we thought of how generative AI fits
within that well first and foremost we
think about this sort of unified data
Foundation right we want to make it
super easy to capture and manage all of
your data make it very easy to bring
different algorithms to bear on that
data and really operate it um at scale
we want to make it simple so that you
don't have to make lots of copies of
data back in the old days of databases
and data warehouses you pull data out of
a database you'd ETL it into a
particular format for us a a schema and
then you would then you know ask the
questions you already knew and if you
had new questions to ask that'd be all
these complicated processes that you'd
need to go to so we really want to kind
of simplify those processes make it easy
for you to run on the data wherever it
is at and then and then finally you know
generative AI is going to be I think
transformational for many businesses and
business processes but for us so far
interestingly the way that we're
integrating it has been sort of very
iterative right a lot of the Investments
our customers have made in their data
and AI Cloud platform their their data
Lake their AI lake house you know if
building on all of that with bigquery
some of the capabilities that we're
launching that I'll talk through you
know they just build on those
foundations you know customers have been
on this journey for many years and we're
going to integrate into that a set of
capabilities to help to help them
and then of course we build this all
um on a super scalable
infrastructure take security very
seriously we want to make sure that all
all data is secure private Etc
so what does bigquery fit in you know we
really see that as at the sort of the
heart of our data and AI Cloud you know
uh thank you very much for uh all of the
uh the customers and the users today I
love hearing the feedback from you know
tens of thousands of customers who are
using the product uh every day
um running billions of queries across
exabytes of data their scale and the
numbers behind the product are really
truly phenomenal so thank you very much
for all of the
um all of the work that you've been
doing uh with uh bigquery
um you know we're building on you know
more than a decade now I was just
looking at the release notes the first
release note for bigquerys 2011. uh we
announced joins you know so we've moved
on a little bit since then and a few
other capabilities
um uh but if I go back over the time
like you know we've been on this little
journey for a while of moving beyond
just you know SQL queries running over
structured data right like we've moved
to different types of programming
languages we've added geospatial
capabilities uh stream analytics we can
stream data in and have queries uh
available to you know instantly query
that data we've reached out to other
clouds through bigquery Omni
um we've extended to data that's outside
of the thought of the traditional data
warehouse management with uh Big Lake
um for customers that want to share data
analytics Hub we've been building ml
into the uh uh into bigquery uh for
years so so lots and lots of innovation
to build on and one thing I do want to
highlight because that you know this is
something I I it was one thing's
actually attracted me to come work at
Google was just some of the underlying
infrastructure is is very very unique
um you know and there's three key parts
right we have a this very very fast uh
scalable file system called Colossus
that means we can write data into it
really really quickly that sits behind
things like the ability for streaming
for example we can stream data in data
is instantly available for query because
we can write it quickly read it
immediately we have Borg which is our
massively scalable compute architecture
that let's scale our query processing
engine Dremel to really large scale and
we can scale up and scale down
dynamically on that and then of course
powering that sort of serverless
architecture that compute storage
separation we have the Jupiter Network
which gives us sort of petabit
connections between our data when you
take these all together it means things
like you know you can stream data in at
just really large scale and have it be
instantly available for query you don't
have to batch load and as you bring data
in data infrastructure you know we we
back huge like tons of disks are act
every day right like we discs fail all
the time you never see any of that right
like just our underlying infrastructure
and reliability means that you know you
can run your workloads very reliably
um efficiency
um you know I talked a little bit about
that compute storage separation it means
we can do some really interesting things
you know you don't have to think about
scaling in units of VMS
um right that are sort of isolated units
of compute um you we have the ability to
allocate resources through reservations
you can scale and share them but we also
can do some really interesting things
like if the capacity isn't being used in
one of your reservations in a few
letters you we can go share it with
other reservations because we have this
you know this large pool of compute that
we're optimizing over right so some very
very powerful uh capabilities um under
the covers
okay so let me talk and go through now
um some of the announcements that we
have so this was mentioned in the
keynote so very excited to introduce a
bigquery studio
um so one of the pieces of feedback we
had from customers is that while you
know your data to AI Journey
um is uh is is very powerful
um but you know what we'd actually like
to do
um a few more things with that and also
can you make it a little bit easier for
us please so a few big things that we're
announcing here is number one we're
going to put a notebook experience
directly inside of uh bigquery so that
Journey from data to AI for folks who
might want to use Python for example is
super simple
um and Beyond just sort of the user
experience integration uh we also wanted
to make it easy to operate and at scale
over data you know often if you're a
data scientists are working with data
that might take a copy of their data at
the warehouse load it into their
notebook work on a subset of the data
there build their algorithm and then you
know figure out about production
productionized running it at scale and
then running it in production so we're
also introducing a data frames API
directly over bigquery so now for anyone
who's working with you know the common
apis that
like so for example pandas will now take
that data frame
API and we'll translate it to uh on the
back end to a query in bigquery so now
you can just run petabyte scale data
frames jobs directly over the data
without even needing to take it out of
uh bigquery so very powerful
capabilities to let you now start a
explore and operate on data and then of
course the other key part is once you
get Beyond experimentation you want to
go into production and so we wanted to
bring much more of the sort of
centralized Source control and revision
history capabilities that you might
expect in a traditional sort of devops
environment into the experience we had
acquired a company a couple of years ago
called dataform that gave us the sort of
the key capabilities for this and so now
you know we can integrate with all of
the kind of the key CI CD workflows that
you might have also integrated in the
experience powered by dataplex is data
profiling data quality data lineage
which will you know as you start to
build these pipelines understanding the
flows of data what's change what's the
quality what's the lineage becomes more
and more important we're going to
integrate that all into the experience
as well so this is a a big announcement
for us this is now going into uh preview
I'm excited for for you all to start to
use that
um I mentioned you know sitting behind
um uh the bigquery studio is data form
helping you now sort of model and build
pipelines giving that um uh integrated
CI CD workflow and orchestration
experience over your data the data
profiling data quality data lineage
capabilities those are actually all
going into
GA now so I'm excited to see those are
being used
um
beyond the sort of the data 2x AI
building experience another big area
we've been investing in is being the
sort of the manage lake house uh with uh
big lake so you know the traditional way
that a data warehouse is built is you'd
have a a query engine a metadata layer
that would deal with table definitions
security
Etc and then a storage layer and that
sort of delivered as a vertical kind of
data warehousing stack
so key thing that we've been working on
is to split the stack apart a little bit
and take that that date that metadata
layer and break it apart um
something that we call a big lake so now
this lets you define metadata Define
security Define tables in a single way
and that and Big Lake will be able to
reach out to data that's in formats like
uh parquet originally and then now we're
also introducing the ability to query
over Iceberg Delta and Hoodie so you can
take data that's in those common formats
you can register it within the big lake
metadable metadata and create tables as
part of uh big lake that are now
available to all of the processing
engine of uh bigquery so very exciting
for customers who might have chosen a
particular open format and they want to
work with and take advantage of the
scale of bigquery uh they can do that
now and again this is powered by that
compute storage separation that I talked
about earlier you know we can store and
manage data separate from compute and
take advantage of the network too to do
that Analytics so in addition to that
you know the other key element of this
is that you can bring different types of
processing to Bear over that data right
so if you want to use dataproc or spark
you can then process and come over the
over big lake data that way so excited
to announce that we we've extended the
formats that are available we're also
introducing fully managed tables uh an
iceberg so not only can you read data
from Iceberg but we will also write so
if you want to write data to these
tables we will take care of transacting
and writing that data for you
um announced earlier in the year
um were something called object tables
um which lets you take data that's in
for example Google Cloud Storage so you
might have one example uses call center
records call center transcripts you
might have a set of call center
transcripts that are sitting in
um in GCS and you might want to do
annotations on them and I'll talk a
little bit later about how you might
apply llama llm algorithms to those
um but you can create a table add a
column that is and make it an object
table by adding a column that's backed
by a bucket of data that's in GCS and
you can operate and secure and manage
that in a single way with uh with big
lake so we really want to be able to
reach to all these different types of
data so you can have a single consistent
way to manage that and then we're
integrating this with other parts of the
stack so for example you can take
algorithms that are invert xai apply
them to data that's in object tables via
Big Lake fine tune models
by pointing your document AI to the data
that's in bigquery and then taking that
algorithm and then productionizing it so
lots and lots of Integrations between
the products to support this uh bigquery
Omni so big for bigquery Omni this is
the ability to reach out to data that is
in AWS and Azure again you know the
principle is we want to be able to
manage your data in a consistent way to
be able to reach out to data that's in
other other clouds we've just recently
announced expansion to uh Island and
Korea
um and uh two new capabilities that are
going into preview
um uh announce that next are the ability
now to join across clouds and also to
create cross-cloud materialized views
um so you can now have a single single
query spanning your Omni and gcp regions
making it very easy now and easier to
sort of share and operate across those
uh just under the covers you might have
seen not too long ago that we announced
uh some Salesforce data Cloud
integration and that actually is powered
under the covers by Omni so you don't
see that as we expose it but if you're
in Salesforce or if you're in bigquery
we make it very easy for you to
interoperate between your different data
sets right we want to make it easy to
sort of secure and manage all of your
data but we also recognize that some of
your data is going to be in other Cloud
providers and in other applications like
other SAS applications like Salesforce
so we want to make it as easy as
possible to connect to that data to
manage that data and operate on it in
your environment
um so analytics hub
so this is something that we announced a
little while ago
um and it uh you know we if you're
working in Industry where you have
suppliers or a supply chain
um or you want to share data sometimes
within your company but often across
companies like how do you do that you
know we we want to make it easy for you
to share and collaborate on your data
with other companies in a safe and
secure way and we have you know
thousands of organizations currently
sharing petabytes of data across those
organizational boundaries right you know
again you might have you have a lot of
data and we'll help you manage the data
within your organizational boundary but
when you want to collaborate with other
organizations that's something that is a
very interesting opportunity as well so
analytics Hub lets you now sort of lets
you curate and manage across those
boundaries and then we're also excited
to preview data clean rooms so this is a
particular set of capabilities so you
might be sharing data sets across
organizations and that's great so long
as you're okay with sharing for example
the contents of that data but if you
have data that is private or or you
don't want to share the details of it
you know you're comfortable with letting
customers run sort of aggregate analysis
on it right like
um like like only showing groups of you
know more than 50 and summations of that
but you want to protect individual uh
privacy
um data clean rooms give you an
environment where you can agree through
policy dial like I will share these
tables and I will give you this join key
and in fact that join key might come
from a third party and then you share it
with another company and you agree that
you can collaborate on that data and
then the results across that so you know
often we see this in you know
third-party cookies you know that are
going away and so sharing of data and
identity between organizations is
becoming more important but customers
want to be able to do that in a secure
way but it doesn't affect the privacy of
their individual customers so now they
can create an environment to share
across two organizations they can take
data that is you know individual data
provide a third-party join key and run
queries over that in a completely safe
secure private way
um and and then we provide algorithms
like K anonymity that says look and you
know we'll only show results if we can
be sure that they're Anonymous to a
factor of say 30 odd people so there's
no way to be able to individually figure
out
um where a piece of data came from so
excited that that is now in preview and
then one other thing that we're going to
announce so this is a roadmap so this is
coming later in the year so continuous
real-time analytics so these are think
of them as sort of continuous query
streaming queries where you can write a
query that is running all of the time
data is written into the system the
query is always responding to that maybe
things like tumbling Windows Etc where
we're able to keep a query running even
as new day later is coming in and
continuously outputting the results
those results can also be output to
other systems like bigtable one common
pattern we hear from customers is I'm
doing a lot of my analytics in bigquery
and then ultimately my serving happens
through a bigtable or for example or
vertex AI sometimes as well and what we
want to be able to do is power that
under the covers so that you know you
don't need to build those pipelines we
can with continuous query just with a
single query now export data directly
into something like bigtable or verdex
so that
um yeah you know your your serving layer
can be always fresh and up to date so
exciting to see what customers are able
to do with that
um okay second section intelligent so
um we announced
um uh as part of our sort of platform
today expanding do it AI more broadly
within Google Cloud platform excited to
bring a number of those announcements
into uh bigquery we'll have a code
assist
natural language assessment assist
SQL completion and all of this will be
all all sort of within a highly secure
Google Cloud environment will operate
over your data in a secure way provide a
really great assistive capabilities over
your data and algorithms
uh for bigquery ML I mentioned earlier
we've been using had bigquery ml built
into bigquery uh for a number of years
and uh we uh are extending that with a
number of capabilities uh to uh call out
to other algorithms so we had some
custom algorithms built into bigquery we
want to make it easier to reach out to
other algorithms through our inference
engine
um so you can go now to pre-trained
models you might have in custom compute
or uh or vertex and we're integrating
also with llm API so that you can now
generate call lime apis and do things
like transcription of text sentiment
analysis on text
Etc
um another roadmap thing that we are
announcing is uh vector embeddings and
indexes
um so often when you're dealing with
um
some of the training data or custom data
to your organization you want to
fine-tune models or uh um and you you
take an embedding which is basically a
sort of a mathematical featurization of
your of your data and you then might
want to you know run that over say you
know 500 images and then ask you know
hey what images are similar well so
we'll make it easy to create those
embeddings and then create an index that
will then have capabilities to do things
like clustering Etc on those and then
you can use these bigquery Vector
indexes to sort of really power your
system of record behind some of the ml
workflows that you will build and then
we'll integrate with so for example
vertex feature star and matching engine
so that you can serve these uh really
really uh quickly as part of your
workflows
um I want to run quickly uh just in the
last couple of minutes before Daniel
comes up uh run through just some other
core platform announcements that we've
had over earlier in the year uh just for
uh completeness
um earlier in the year we introduced a
number of new ways to sort of manage and
think about overall price performance
and total TCO we introduced three
additions in bigquery we introduced an
auto scaler and we introduced a new uh
format of storage for compressed storage
giving more choices on um on how to
manage your overall TCO depending on the
different workloads that you have as
part of that auto scaling was released
so this is an auto scaler that lets you
now run a query in a capacity-based
model we'll scale the query up to meet
the needs of your workload and then as
that workload dies down we'll scale back
down capacity and then we'll just bill
you for the
um that capacity that we've scaled to so
it's fine grain scaling and then coming
down as well we want to make it as
simple as possible so you don't have to
think about managing capacity as you're
running workloads
um lots of improvements on performance
we've been working on over the uh over
the year I put some examples here many
of these you'll see our goal is to
simplify it so we do things under the
covers like adapted file sizing to deal
with different size of data sets
um
Dynamic concurrency control so lots of
things that we're just continuing to
work on under the covers to include
improve our price performance another
good core capability table snapshots and
clones so you can have a table a data
set and you might want to be a you might
want to take a copy of that so that you
can then think about backups or or
reading off of it or you might want to
clone a Setter and those are read-only
replicas if you want to then snapshots
if you want to then clone a table so
that you might want to do some a b
testing or production testing you can
create a writeable clone as well so
these are two great capabilities that
were announced earlier in the year
migration Services making it easier to
move various workloads from a range of
different
targets to bigquery we're enhancing our
migration capabilities with llms so that
we can simplify those last minute uh
those last mile translations you saw
some demonstrations of that for
databases in the keynote this morning
hopefully and just making it easier for
you to interact with this through an API
and then finally
um I just want to talk a little bit
about Partners so you know we really
believe in having a really cohesive Rich
Partner ecosystem so very excited to
continue to grow and work with those
Partners
um one thing we've been excited to do
which is now uh generally available uh
just a little earlier in the year was
actually build within the bigquery
experience a partner Center experience
so making it easier to discover partner
Integrations uh having customized
getting started experiences and we'll
build on that in the future with better
in in context
um experiences as well so I think with
that that's my section complete Daniel
is going to take over for five ten
minutes and then we will take a q a
[Applause]
thank you Dave I'm continuously
impressed by the iterations feed on
bigquery so many cool things coming out
this year
yeah I'm Daniel I come from Discord I
represent the data platform team
very happy to be here
[Applause]
so
oops I go the wrong way
cool so a little bit about Discord we
were founded in 2015 we are a place
where the world goes to hang out it's
text voice and video communication
and we have 150 monthly active users
some of the interesting data challenges
we face as a company is that it's a
real-time platform texting and voice
it's very quick so we need to be able to
react to Data Insights very quickly in
order to be successful in our mission an
example of this is that we banned 300
million spam accounts last year
so the goals of our platform let me look
at okay here we go
yeah when we set out on our journey with
bit with bigquery
uh we set out with three goals the first
one is self-service data platform
because Discord we believe in small and
mighty teams providing High leverage to
our customers and stakeholders
and in the data platform that meant data
governance data quality observability
and all of the tools people need to
operate their own data sets
independently from a central team
scalability this is a way to unlock
growth without us going back to the
drawing board every couple times
and multi-purpose as we've seen the uses
for bigquery has grown every year with
the expansion of gen AI
but even from the beginning we knew that
we needed analytics business
intelligence ml experimentation causal
inference and a multitude of different
requirements in order for us to meet
these needs an example is we built our
own reverse ETL system at Discord and
now bigquery came along and released it
themselves this year
so
the circumstances and impact what was
basically the beginning of our journey
with bigquery it started in 2019
actually right before I got to Discord
when the team had reached the maximum
size of the redshift cluster so we knew
that we were going to have to pick a new
redshift cluster but costs had also
become a problem so they went to First
principles and
they arrived at bigquery and honestly
I'm very thankful they did because I
took over the data platform team in 2020
two months before covet hit so we hit
500 percent increase in event volume in
a two-month window right after we went
on bigquery and it really uh it was very
useful very very helpful
um so yeah also uh data quality and data
governance
data governance is a key piece because
every year the compliance landscape
becomes more complicated
and historically workflows were blocked
by a centralized team
and we had course gain coarse grained
data governance controls which meant
that frequently we would just lock
people out of data or delete it
so this is where we started and I'm
going to tell you a little bit about the
journey
uh here's our architecture so at the
bottom of this diagram I think is the
critical piece which is our self-service
data platform
this is where we've realized that what
stakeholders need in order to
to accomplish their goals is they need
to
operate independently within the company
so for us that means providing
observability data quality checks
metadata management as well as automated
data data governance policies so there's
still centralized places within the
company that Define the process for data
governance but when they actually go to
do their day-to-day work policy
automation comes out of the box
so the benefits and value that we've
learned through our journey
the first one was actually just
continuous integration and deployment
some things continuously deploy other
things we have human steps along the way
especially with data governance ensuring
that there is verification before things
go to production but the ability for
people to deploy rapidly has really
increased the speed and the quality of
data throughout the system
and scalable we've put bigquery through
the ringer a couple times in the past
couple years one time we scaled from a
hundred thousand slots to 170 000 slots
in uh one day
shout out to Zay methani she was on the
other side of that call when we formed
whether we needed 70 000 more cores like
at that moment and then most importantly
the ability for us to scale back down so
once this great need was over we could
scale back down and not be paying paying
for more than we needed
and then lastly data governance and
quality honestly I see it more of a as
an ecosystem around bigquery bigquery is
like the the foundational piece but
um
yeah DLP dataplex and now a lot of it's
going directly into bigquery with
bigquery policy tags has allowed us to
automate policies and Implement
fine-grained data governance policies
making it easier for data to be
accessible across the company
whoops
so yeah lessons learned it's been quite
a journey but what we definitely learned
is that bigquery does scale efficiently
and workload management is a key piece
of us achieving uh cost and performance
one of the important ones I like to
always call out is uh we build execution
projects to dedicate bigquery slot
reservations and you can attach bi
engine to to Dedicated ones so you can
get low latency query access and
quick responsive business intelligence
but based on your use case you can
allocate the resources and I think that
was a critical piece
uh Lessons Learned is that self-service
does unlock teams teams are just waiting
when we provide them the observability
tools the policy automation it it was
quickly adopted
data governance is much easier when
everyone contributes this is something
that no matter how many tools we've
built and how many systems we put in
place some of the highest leverage value
we've had is through education across
the company and
everybody participating so that we can
have a robust privacy compliance and
data governance system
and lastly data ownership increases
collaboration and data quality so as we
provided the tools for people to claim
ownership of their data sets
it's allowed our stakeholder teams to
have 10x leverage across the company
sharing their high quality data products
to other teams
that's just a little bit about our
journey on bigquery
[Music]
foreign